hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft galaxy heute an diesem
tag für mich ist es immer noch der
gleiche tag an dem auch die letzten drei
folgen aufgenommen wurden und diese
folgen wird auch an diesem gleichen tag
sein und die folge morgen am dienstag
auch ich hoffe ich bleibe jetzt nichts
falsches und ich hoffe es hat alles
geklappt mit dem ablauf ich bin erst mal
kurz ein bisschen offtopic hier während
ich hier so ein bisschen rum kuriosum
paar von diesen coolen pinken bäumen so
einen pinken baum brauche ich und diese
farbe muss sich irgendwo auf dieser
karte suchen das hier sind ja diese viel
zu dunklen lila bäume schaue immer noch
so ein bisschen über die map drüber da
es so einer million weg sonst ist ja
keine aber sonst muss ich glaub ich
wirklich so weit fliegen
für seinen da es noch einer die ok da
dann fliegt einfach mal hin
ein bisschen oft ob ich gerade in meinem
leben dazu abgeht ich bin perfekt das
wirklich einer
ich bin freitag war ich mit einem freund
in den urlaub warte mal das habt ihr
glaube ich schon gestern sogar gesehen
in dem kontakt wenn ich irgendwas gerade
sack und ihr denkt euch höre ich hab das
gestern gar nicht gesehen
dann denkt euch nicht höhe habe ich
irgendwas verpasst hat dem was nicht
hochgeladen blablabla nee dann habe ich
wohl einfach irgendwie man hat hat
minister nicht hingekriegt
wenn ich später umziehe nach hamburg
dann ist es so dann habe ich dann
100.000 der unitymedia leitung und dann
kann ich da einfach ganz viele videos
hochladen dann ist alles geplant
allerdings ist es zurzeit so mit meiner
16.000 leitung mit meinem buch ab lauter
das ist das falsche holzes brauche ich
gar nicht dass letztlich einfach ganz
schnell wieder zurück so mir da keine
natur irgendwie zerstört wird das ist
halt so ich brauche für ein video für
den upload drei stunden lang
das heißt ich fange jetzt am mittwoch an
vor zu produzieren
das kein holz vergessen und jetzt auch
noch heute ich war jetzt am mittwoch an
vor zu produzieren
dann lade ich die ganze sache am
donnerstag von 10 uhr morgens hoch und
dann sind das galaxy für freitag samstag
sonntag montag dienstag das in fünf
folgen galaxy das in 15 stunden die dann
mein pc ab 10 uhr hochlädt bis 1 uhr
nachts dann mache ich nun aus und ich
hoffe da klappt alles
ich hoffe da legt sich alles dann von
selbst hoch et cetera pp
ich kann euch da nichts versprechen die
fig jetzt auch noch der ganz hinten und
ich glaube es reicht sogar schon kann
man sein dass das schon reicht
ich hoffe dass alles klappt es sollte
eigentlich alles klappen
und dann wird es auch alles super und
wenn alles gut klappt hatte dann könnte
das daran erkennen dass heute wenn ihr
diese folge hat seht es montag dann
hätte alles bisher gut geklappt
ich will jetzt einfach ein passivhaus zu
bekommen dass eventuell noch ein paar
mehr von diesen bäumen anpflanzen kann
dann hat jedenfalls alles super geklappt
denn heute gerade montag ist wenn heute
dienstag oder mittwoch ist oder
irgendein anderer tag dann hat es nicht
gut geklappt also wenn alles heute das
nicht montag ist dann ist oft aber ich
bin halt im urlaub ich bin an der
nordsee lafarge öfters mal hin mit einem
kumpel chris heißt der vielleicht kennt
ihr den von meinem 2 kanal wieder filmt
steht doch in der beschreibung
da haben wir damals mal zwei videos oder
ein video zusammen gemacht aber da durch
den kanal ein bisschen vernachlässigt
und mit christian von mir so viel
gemacht auch relativ weit auseinander
wurden und jetzt fahren wir zusammen in
urlaub und es wird alles mega chillig
und filmt auch ein paar sachen zu
bewegen die am 3
langlaufen oder keine ahnung wenn wir
irgendwo sind halt so wir sind da ganz
gute freunde und dann eurocom habe sogar
noch ein holz entdeckt hier wunderschön
ach guck mal jetzt auf einmal hier ne
ich kann ja alles abbauen müssen ja
klasse hätte dann hätte der baum
dahinter auch schon zerfallen müssen es
denn wohl auch noch irgendwo einen holz
jedenfalls muss ich halt alles
vorproduzieren deswegen nehme ich die
folgen auf jetzt gerade nicht mit ihnen
kann ich die nicht noch mal mit malte
oder mit patrick oder mit irgendwem
anders aufnehmen mit dem ich so ein
bisschen schmecken könnte weil die halt
dann alle diese folge auch erst vier
tage später hochladen müssten damit die
zeitgleich kommen und das will ich den
nicht zumuten und da will ich dann auch
nicht so blöd
ja komm rat jedoch vier tage später
möchte ich nicht die soll das alles
selbst entscheiden
und ich find's super das macht und
petric fest auch an den baum hier dass
der das so ein bisschen blockiert
das hier ist mit gemacht habe es war ja
auch eigentlich ein was witzig bisschen
feierlich aber es lag nicht an dem baum
elferrat überlegt das denn hier ist
allerdings ohne holz oder hier liegt
bestimmt auch richtig irgendwo hier
zwischen es richtig sieht jedoch so ein
holzblock euro
hier ist nix drin vielleicht sehe ich es
auch nix ich muss aber doch ein holz
sein sonst wird er doch theoretisch auch
auseinanderfallen zornig quali handvoll
übersehen dass hier noch einer ist
wunderschön
ich hoffe wirklich einfach nur ich
quatsche ich hier wieder
ich hasse das immer so wenn ich weiß
dass ich mich total ablenken lassen
nicht auf den punkt komme und ich hasse
das auch als zuhörer immer ich sie dann
manche videos im titel
okay da und darum geht und dann redet
die personaler und wider der pause
bleibt im game
dann macht sie wieder dies dann sondern
sich auch aufs thema konzentrieren denke
ich immer dann gehe ich wieder total
schnell weg von dem video ich hasse
solche leute und ich bin ja selber so
einer ich kann das nicht abschalten dass
ich mich total ablenken lasse ich muss
jedenfalls richtig richtig viel vor
produzieren
und gerade wenn man ne scheiß leitung
hat es das vorproduzieren stellt sich
als sehr mühsam dar
deswegen hoffe ich und wünsch mir auch
für euch und auch für mich dass das
ganze klappt es wird nacht ich find's
super dass das jetzt mit malte und
patrick schön machen könnte ich finde
auch das haus wird langsam aber ich kann
nichts versprechen wenn die folge grad
am montag kommt das alles super soll
sowie sechs minuten darüber gelacht
ihr seht dann auch wahrscheinlich am
sonntag also habt ihr dann gestern
gesehen
für mich ist das also daran noch in
weiter ferne noch mittwoch ist ich hoffe
ich habe das schöne aufnahmen für euch
gemacht von der fahrt mit dem fischerweg
schief geht hat er super gut
da sieht man relativ viel und von
unserem flug vielleicht auch noch
mussten müssen muss ich mal gucken wie
ich das dann irgendwie noch zusammen
schneidet damit ihr das gestern gesehen
habt
das ist super dass es bis ich hab den 2
ein paar sachen gegeben aber dafür geben
die noch sachen zurück und das halt
schön da kann man freunden weiterhelfen
und die geben einem sachen zurück das
ist genauso wie wenn man in der branche
investiert und nachzuhaken
was ihr macht für die korrekte leute
gebäude 1 millionen euro und dann nach
zehn jahren hat sich das ganz weiter weg
und kriegt also zurück weil wenn jetzt
irgendwann wenn malte auf einmal sich
heftig informiert über alles und es
richtig gut dabei und ich immer noch
einmal beim einem hausbau hier einfach
mal kommen
damit lade ach komm ich geb dir dat und
dort das ist alles super eagles auf
jeden fall erstmal immer genug zu
fressen mit dann habe ich das hier alles
zu fressen mit um ein holz park stellen
in die holzkiste die ganzen kisten muss
ich noch mal alle wirklich richtig
komplett sortieren
bei den hammer bergmann ich da kommt
erst mal diese utensilien kiste hier den
dass er muss immer dabei haben diesen
minden stuff freue mich die ak auch
nicht aus sind diamanten kann ich mir
noch eine putz und hell machen
dann habe ich eine full die rüstung
boots moment putz und helm so so so so
dann kann ich das zum beispiel der
nächsten folge dann auch weiter geben
sodann durch jemand die sachen wieder
rein und die kakaobohnen kann ich jetzt
endlich mal einfach aufessen
das ist aber echt cool ich wusste dass
gar nicht an diese kakaobohnen essen
kann food + strawberry das extra berrys
verstehe nicht dass mit trouble
verstehen die muss ich einen gerechten
draufmachen food + also vielleicht was
er aufgewachsen groß rechtsweg
strawberry kropp richter doch das war
noch nicht fertig ja gut dann ja gut
habe ich gesagt habe habe ich sehr sehr
cool mit den erdbeeren
das ist super das gefällt mir dass ich
eher appell an pflanzen kann golf major
er kommt einfach raus stark was
verseuchte mit reis kann ich in ihm wie
kochen oder so wie gesagt scheut euch
nicht wie das also ein kommentare zu
schreiben von mir aus kempten wie sonst
was ich habe ja nichts gegen rheydt
redstone lemm pflicht was gibt mir das
denn es gibt in welche teil und habe ich
gerade irgendwie habe ich die klubs
kommt wieder runter gemacht hier
es hat mir das denn jetzt gegeben klug
an deck minecraft konnten bis zur wall
street wohl so ach so komplett voll
ich mag dass man einfach alles hier ein
so habe ich hier eigentlich schon immer
mal die seals reingepackt ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich das alles sortiert hatte
sodann die coffee bean scorpions habe
ich die ganze zeit koffeins gegessen da
kein platz mehr
also wie gesagt ich glaube ich mache
jetzt in ich bin mir jetzt noch zwei von
alleine auf ich versuche jetzt mal
produktiv zu sein ich das hier erst mal
wieder den stumpf fahrer hier mithin ja
vorhin abgebaut weil ich dachte es sieht
nicht gut aus aber es ging eigentlich
schon das darum mal ab aber ich fahre
wandel mich mal ganz kurz zurück in mich
selber damit ich da so ein bisschen
größer bin schönsten drei blog großen
ort begeben motto motto abgebe oder
unterschiede erkennen ob monster mod
modifikation hatten habe ich auch
wirklich einige frage wieso hast du dich
berichtigt by modus doch richtig wieder
gibt es einen gewissen unterschied vng
gehört jedoch nicht muss man diese facts
folge jetzt vor drehen perfekt es immer
so viel aufwand sonne folge aufnehmen
hier ist wirklich nur weil die facts
folge kürzer sei ja nicht gleich dass
die weniger aufwand ist ich finds noch
immer traurig muss jetzt mal echt sagen
muss ich über voll heulender aber noch
hier zwei wollte vor allem kürzer machen
wir die letzten folgen immer überzogen
haben
und ich mich schon am anfang beschwert
dass da einige wie die 18 minuten eine
folge gemacht haben jetzt hab ich selber
so wie viele leute wir sind immer leid
wenn die leute dann zum einen in unserer
stadt conti-aktien alle und ich habe
auch überzogen das ist schon ein
bisschen doof und ja weil sie nicht also
kein holz mehr
menschenskinder ihnen einfach mal das
bauen wir mit
wenn wir kein holz haben dann welche als
auch gerade wieder runter gesprochen
möchte ich die folgen ein bisschen
kürzer halten nicht mich klingt das
immer so ein bisschen wenn unter den
folgen hat so steht aber alles nur
geklaut das regt mich aber so auf da bin
ich echt wirklich einfach nur traurig
weil die facts kommen quasi von euch im
mac hat damit quasi nicht selbst dann
aber die leute die mir das zu senden
und das regt mich dann auch mal so ein
bisschen auf weil ich sage immer ja es
schickt mir fakes bitte die ihr selbst
heraus gefunden habt oder die euch wer
gezeigt hat aber nicht irgendwo einem
video gesehen hat noch die serie keinen
sinn weil man kann kann ich auch direkt
auf das video verweisen das macht dann
keinen sinn
ich habe extra verantworten gesagt die
serie ersetzt quasi ersetzt nicht aber
ich habe damals mal sowas gemacht dass
ich so leute gepusht habe dass ich
gesagt habe okay es ist ein guter
canalis durch let's putz genannt man
sehr viele von beeindruckt von diesem
format steht den eigentlichen crafting
table gar keinen sinn
einfach mal weg damit und ich hab dann
diese effektvoll gemacht hab mir gedacht
okay ich das mache dann will ich das
nicht so machen dass ich mir die ganzen
facts wie er aussieht oder so sondern
dass die von euch kommen dass die chance
hat ok kommen ihr schreibt eine mail
und dann habt ihr eine gewisse chance
dass ihr in dem nächsten video dabei
seid und boa war es knapp wünsche dir so
böse geguckt weil ich dachte explodiert
hier aber das ist jetzt vielleicht meine
chance dass ich da wieder ein bisschen
anfordert bekomme das jetzt einfach mal
da unten drin für dich erstmal die hier
kurz mit dem thema fliegen wenn man eine
fledermaus ist ein neuer wald geschleppt
hat halo reach wenn eine frau sich
kleiden dass man mit dem teil auf einer
höhe
wieso kann ich denn keine gelder
einsammeln das ist das findet doofe
sache jetzt je wieder schöne erfahrung
muss auch mal irgendwann verzaubern
zwischen 21 level ich wollte die folge
ja auch eigentlich kürzer halten aber
die hat seinen hut herr doktor gut ich
würde sagen ich beende die folge weil
ich die nicht so lange machen will wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lassen wir
wert und ich hab ein bisschen gelabert
nichts erreicht aber euch ein bisschen
darüber informiert was in zukunft hier
kommt dann macht ihr der nächsten folge
mein dach ein bisschen weiter aber noch
ein bisschen
und dann müsste ich dann auch schon
wieder aus dem urlaub zurück sein
ich muss ja vom server unter ich würde
schon als ganzes hier